[Applause]
the protests are getting angrier
people from across the community around
anderton park
primary school came to join in after
this leaflet was sent out
by the protest organisers it's okay to
be gay
you can have two mummies you can have
two daddies you can be a girl in a boy's
body
i mean you can this is this is so
against the word of god
these men don't have children at the
school but came to show their support
homosexuality is a it's a heinous
horrible thing
overall it's not acceptable in islam god
created man and then he created woman
for man's pleasure
and for his companionship he did not
create man for man i mean that is a
disgusting act
but it's all that for your children to
sit around the table and talk about gay
lesbians uh
openly that's fine that's within your
christian opportunity but with us
with us we don't accept it we don't
accept we cannot trust
the headmistress in there abdullah bam
is a parent
and teacher from batley in west
yorkshire he's been in touch with the
protest organizers here in birmingham
he told me he's setting up a national
campaign
we're creating a parent pack something
similar
to this yeah on there there'll be some
uh what's up groups that
parents can join and we're going to put
it out there
i mean this is the kind of material
that's absolutely horrific
for five-year-old seven-year-olds it's
unbelievable if you read
some of that material so the books for
what's wrong with it
um well it's sexualizing material and
gender confusing material that's what's
wrong with it
this is going to go national parents are
going to complain like this
and schools better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who
aren't parents at the school head
teachers have told me that they're
concerned about the kind of
information that's being given to
parents via whatsapp groups and online
about what's being taught in schools
they say it's misinformation
it's upsetting parents and it's not true
daily protests have been taking place
outside this school for weeks
but this is the largest demonstration so
far
parents are now threatening to withdraw
their children from school for a day on
monday
we're not all here wasting time because
we've got nothing better to do
we're standing here because we want to
be heard the school's head teacher said
the vast majority of protesters are not
parents
spoiling a child's education risking
unauthorized absence fines
having an authorized absence on a
child's records creating division
between school and families where there
wasn't any before
and all because it's important for
children to know and understand that
some people have two mummies
it is quite unbelievable vicky is a
local muslim mother who supports the
school
we are taught everyone has the freedom
to wear what they want and believe in
what they want and
have a lifestyle which they're choosing
that's the best thing about being
in britain and i think it's so important
the headteacher says seeking to divide
communities and plant doubt in
children's minds about their teachers
is unforgivable becky johnson sky news
birmingham